today's monday minute is no excuses
if you have a goal you need to take
action every day to move closer to that
goal
and not give yourself excuses why you
can't do something today
i'll do it tomorrow i'll do it tomorrow
but i can't do it today because
of this great excuse i want to become a
better snowboarder
okay and yesterday i wake up i look at
the weather it's minus 31 degrees
outside
minus 31 degrees it's crazy it's cold
and i could have said i'm not gonna go
it's too cold and you know what the next
day i could have said oh the conditions
aren't great oh there's not enough
powder
i'm too tired to go you can always come
up with an excuse why you can't do
something
and you can say i'm gonna wait for the
conditions to be perfect before i go out
the conditions are never perfect if you
wait for the conditions to be perfect
to make your dream a reality then you're
going to be sitting on your dream for
the rest of your life
if you want something you go get it you
start taking action and do something
today
to move you closer to that goal no more
excuses
believe you guys like this video give it
a thumbs up below
let me know what you think with a
comment subscribe to the channel you see
more videos
thank you so much and i'll see you soon